what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here
you think i'm gonna leave you out in the
cold it's a beautiful thursday [__]
morning
i figured i'd come out here check up on
any [__]
smoke a number with you what the [__] is
going on you know what i'm saying
it's been a great week i'm in my new
house
i'm feeling a lot better i joined the
gym
furniture comes on friday i got a
barbecue on saturday
sunday i had some but there was a death
in the family tonight so it's a
nightmare but what are you gonna do
we keep pushing on
and you know me regardless of what's
going on i want to check in with you
guys on patreon you're my patreon family
it's [__] thursday you know
what i'm saying joey where the [__] you
been up in here
but i've been busy i gotta take the kid
to the [__] beach
school starts on the eighth i go into
[__] uh
quarantine for the sopranos i'm done new
podcast october 1st
then i'll attack stand up i was
stressing myself out
about this stand up [__] you know what i
got a lot of things on my plate right
now
for right now let's take one thing at a
time
i want to do the best i can on patreon i
want to do the best i can on this new
podcast
i want to do best i can on the joey diaz
project on patreon i just do for you
guys nobody else
and that's in that said i'm still
smoking the california urethra
i got tons of this [__] you know me dog
i don't travel like
i come with the whole [__] army
i don't even know what this is i took
the labels off and i'm just playing mix
and match now
do what you need to do you know what i'm
saying
but i love you guys i was thinking about
you guys let me tell you what's going on
i've been stressing this [__] stand
up lately
i don't want to stand up right now i'm
not feeling it you're not you know
i'm not feeling it right now 29 years
the last nine have been on fire i
appreciate your support and love
but for right now i can't be worrying
about stand up and doing spots at night
i haven't written the joke tomorrow
today the third of september will be
six months since i've been on stage six
[__] months
you think about that that's a long
[__] time you know what i did 29
years
so my chops are still there my legs are
still there the other thing that's still
not there is my head in my heart they're
not together they're not aligned
and if they're not aligned stand up is
out of [__]
i drove to the stress for factory
tonight i was going to do 10 minutes
but there were two shows i got that 8 30
and the the show was going to start at 9
30.
i had to meet somebody then to get a
[__] envelope and to drop something
off on them
so and then before i went to drop the
envelope i got the call
the dear friend had passed away so i
thought it was a [__] wrench that
means one day next week i got to put on
a black suit
and i feel horrible about it but when i
feel horrible i go to you guys
the same way when you feel horrible you
come to me hey listen
guys there's the church family
and uh we'll [__] uh evolve into a
different family
you know like the [__] uh before the
gambinos was the [__] whatever and
they became the gambinos
we'll move over again what do we do
that's why i don't like talking and
smoking because the [__] joint goes
out you get those people that
hold on to the joint and they want to
decide to tell you a long story and
you're looking at the joint like
smoke the joint then talk [__]
that's me tonight
but anyway it's been a great week the
family's happy
i did this for the family this is why
and we're all happy to tell you when to
be look at the suntan
looking [__] smoking went down a
point pleasant
got some shrimp tacos didn't touch the
fries
i joined the gym i'm ready to go that's
it
a little bit every day little steps
towards
what i was doing in l.a okay except with
a twist
no stand up let's [__] shoot this
movie
let's get my daughter in school let's
get this podcast together
i'm thinking of a bunch of different
ideas and different ways to do this
and then we'll worry about [__]
standard for right now
yeah i'm not feeling it you're not
feeling something i'm not feeling it
and the last three times i went to do it
there was a problem so that's god giving
you a [__] sign remember i told you
you get signs that's a sign i'm
bullshitting
i get signs all the [__] time
no edibles tonight just straight up
brief
writing answering your emails on [__]
patreon because that's what i do
i take pride in that uh that's very big
try to welcome as many of you as i can
but who gives a [__] this background
music it's me and you [__]
tomorrow morning you're gonna wake up to
a tremendous [__] beat
i'm picking it out in my head right now
i'm gonna get you fired up so you can
stab three [__] clowns
and one [__] you know what i'm saying
i don't even know if you want to do it
in that order
i don't know what your stabbing
capabilities are but whatever the [__]
they are
i'm with you you with me and these
[__] want to be with us
it's patreon [__] it's a mind
of joey dears
as you could tell the echo is loud
because i got no furniture don't get hit
till friday
so i got limited amount of clothes
thank god i brought a kettlebell and two
[__] club badges to do a little mini
workout
in the house we were in last week when
there was a pool so i swam every day
i took walks with my daughter but
weights awaits i love throwing around
some metal it makes me breathe the right
way it covers my
brings down my blood pressure and
lifting weights goes a long way you know
i'm saying you burn calories throughout
the day so
i'm a weight guy beside that that's it
i'm happy if you see the video from last
week you look at the video today i'm two
different [__] people why because of
you
because i took your advice i
i took your advice i took my own advice
and together it's like g
kundo you know what i'm saying not
everything works little bits and pieces
this guy's got an idea this guy's got an
idea everybody has an idea next thing
you know boom
we're [__] working i'm about 80 right
now
joey shut the [__] up tell these people
to [__] story but smoke that [__]
joke i hear you kind of sucking but i
got things to do
anyway i got the church on representing
old school
for you [__] i'm happy you
enjoyed the last episode you liked the
little present i gave you huh
i don't [__] around dog oh yeah well
that bingo i had it planned all along
i knew would come there andy and what a
better gift to give you on the way out
i love paulie shaw no disrespect for
paulie sure but it was a good [__]
podcast i laughed my ass off so
that's what happens when you hang out
with uncle joey make sure
don't even touch his hand he's got thc
fingers
and you're gonna end up getting [__]
i got some tremendous edibles here
i took one the on that i was bent over
right when i went to straighten up
i felt they're coming to me i felt like
[__] jesus on the [__] cross they
all dizzy and [__]
looking onto the horizon i was all
[__] up i enjoyed it i made it i
barely made it to bed nobody knew
nothing you know me i'm keeping under
wraps
tomorrow night i'm going up north to see
my [__] buddies
i've been seeing my friends a lot i
leave here about seven
i get to the house about eight we go in
their backyard
we each have our own numbers we talk
some [__]
i turn around and come up today i don't
know where i'm going i don't know i'm
not familiar with new jersey
so i gotta start all over again it's
been [__]
1993 so i don't know where the [__] i'm
going so i've been venturing out
i do with waves so i don't get lost you
know me i got a little app on my phone
and 1200 feet make a left turn i got to
get that [__] job
hit it [__] cut that [__] asian
off who gives a [__] at this point in
the game who's watching cops ain't
giving tickets
anyway i'm not gonna like this [__]
thing again i'm talking to you cocos
i love you i'm happy you're here i'm
happy we're together
i'm happy we get to do this from time to
time
you know me if i could do this every day
it'd be being you till the wheels fall
off but for right now
we got what we got and we'll work with
it because that's what we do
i give you from time to time i check in
with your [__] suckers why because i
love you
the dollar i don't give a [__] about the
dollar i'm giving you more than what a
dollar's worth [__] that [__]
the dollar is your commitment that i
don't get those [__] lunatics and
facebook saying [__]
and blowing [__] bubbles and sending
me pictures of [__]
[__] with dicks on them i don't need
that in my life i'm a christian you know
what i'm saying thinking of starting a
rehab
a new kind of rehab reefer acupuncture
and comedy
if that don't get you so but nothing
will uncle joey's rehab we take it to a
camp
we [__] you know get your dick sucked
and you monkey ate one last time
and then it's all over then you're on
reefer therapy
acupuncture and [__] comedy shows at
night and taking notes [__]
because i don't want you drifting into
[__] heroinville or whatever the [__]
[__] oxycontinville
if anybody can do a rehab it's uncle
joey you know what i'm saying i could
see it now uncle joey's rehab 1-800
no credit don't come down here
[__] we take cash only
so you better save some of that loot you
rob from the drug dealer
and the other thing is i ran out of my
good papers
i had to use some [__] papers out of
my luggage some stuff making papers
tomorrow
i'll stop by the chronicle whatever the
[__] they got and get some nice papers
for you [__]
i gotta get the papers get the papers
anyway
i didn't forget about you guys i've been
hitting you with the daily messages
i did those two little [__] things
for you you know me dude i'm gonna keep
you on schedule don't worry about none
i still got you monday and wednesday on
patreon a little something
just as a [__] reminder there's an
apparent teeth
that uncle joey didn't go nowhere i
ain't underground ain't doing nothing
i'm just trying to [__] uh
be a father be a good husband and
[__] hang out in the house and
help out because you know you buy a
house all of a sudden you become johnny
carpenter i don't know nothing
last time i strong i am i got four years
you know what i'm saying
no i didn't that's a [__] joke people
last time i swallowed that
what the [__] knows i gotta measure [__]
i gotta take down particle board and
paint i'm gonna make it look nice
a little boxing area you know me i like
hitting the bag from time to time
i like smoke in the bag snorting the bag
and hitting the bag i don't give a [__]
i don't smart no more but i smoked the
bag and i get in the bag
beside that that's it and that's that
i got a podcast coming for you monday
morning
right here on patreon wednesday and i'll
fill you in on what's going on
you know this debt is heavy i haven't
fully absorbed it yet
but uh she was very good to me at one
time when i moved back here in
1993 she was pregnant
and uh her husband worked nights
and he would tell me to go over and
watch her at night and i'd sit with it
and we watched goodfellas and we'd order
chinese food at [__] 10 30.
it was tremendous did that for about
three months
then i had to move on i moved on with
george i [__] started doing comedy in
the city
but uh we became tight in those three
months you've been dating my brother
since
86.
life is life i know how to keep it
together a little more when uh
death you know i'm so used to that that
i
mourn differently than people between us
i didn't want to leave la because i
felt like i was leaving ralphie there
you know that that's how much
he's still a part of me on my phone i
still got brody i still you know
you know me though i'm a [__] school
what are you gonna do but
we got each other that's why i came out
here tonight to talk to you
check in with you make sure you're right
nobody's bothering you
and uh we'll put this [__] together like
we always do
covered all this [__] it's gonna pass
and [__] like us
are still gonna be here we're gonna be a
little wounded it's gonna take a little
time to get back but trust me
i've been in wars before this one ain't
dick we're walking we're breathing
you know what i'm saying you're
consolidating you're downsizing what you
probably needed to do anyway
there's a silver lining dollars i told
you this march 17 march 18th podcast
i told you this is a silver lining to
all this so whatever your [__] you're
going through
get over it smoke a joint get that
[__] notebook
and get ready for the next chapter of
your life the same way i'm getting ready
for the next chapter in my [__] life
okay
that's what was bothering me this last
anxiety that i had went away just now
from talking to you [__]
because we got to get over it tonight i
answered 200 emails everybody's going
through a rough patch yeah
everybody's going through a real rough
patch you know what that means you got
to get out of the rough patch how do you
do that
you make a [__] plan and you work the
steps
to the [__] t you don't [__]
deviate you understand me
and eventually you get to that place
where you need to go who did it before
i did it so i'm living [__] proof so
if i can do it i got a geb and i'm a
[__] [__]
could you imagine what you could do get
a joint
put your head together get your head
together and get back to me
i love you guys with all my heart patron
family thank you for what you're doing
it wasn't about the dollar it was about
putting us close together
so now i know who's in and who's out if
you're out i don't give a [__]
if you're in i'm gonna go all in and
that's the way i played a [__]
game whether you like it or not what are
you gonna do
it's too late it's a [__] dollar what
are you gonna sue me for a [__]
dollar
i'm here giving you [__] love and
giving you the same thing you've given
me belief
well i'm seeking the same thing i've
given you relief
you know i'm saying at the same time we
get stoned
and everybody gets happy and it's a good
[__] thursday
i love you guys with all my heart knock
it out of the [__] park today
whatever you're feeling
push it aside just for today just for
you uncle joey you know what i'm saying
because i'm gonna be feeling something
too and i'm gonna push it aside
i'll be answering your emails today i'll
be doing something i'll pull a rabbit
out of my ass out of something right
today all right
have a great [__] day stay blessed
god bless you
that's the cat i think she got the flu
uh
i love you [__] all my heart
stay black all right